times change
you do what you gotta do think it's most
employers don't want mothers it's a
competitive market you don't know me
for money
you survived
now might be the time so what feel my
husband's have 24 months left on her
services sorry baby
this is divers mama organized crimes
we're gonna take care of you your girl's
gonna be just fully we got no money
can't even make the rent with what they
gave me last night they didn't want me
in the family in the first place 40
years they pay protection and we don't
get nothing for it I have been homeless
for effort that we are never gonna do
anything but have babies bunch of men
that have forgotten what family means so
we remind them no pretty mama pretty
doesn't matter it's just a tool women
used what anything we want what do you
want can see you got brains and I know
you got money but we got one thing that
you don't
criminals so you can't go around walking
for a bunch of women they are not
smarter than me I will wipe you off the
face of the earth I don't want you to
die
I want you to teach me how to it
just to be clear now we run this
neighborhood
step off my business baby it's my
business left they're gonna swallow this
entire city you go to war
there's no coming back also Caretti
wants to talk if we go to Brooklyn we're
dead
what are you where does something like
that get dressed up kitty
[Music]
my god I lost count again
[Music]